mark Elwood contributing editor at Conde
Nast Traveler joins us now with more
mark good morning
we've all been cooped up for so long I
guess the only opportunity we have now
is to explore our own backyards in a
sense what does that look like in terms
of actually venturing out so I think
it's really interesting there was a
recent survey that looked at what most
Americans were planning to do in terms
of vacations and about 41% of them said
hey we're gonna drive about a hundred
miles from our home so we are calling
this sort of the all-american summer
staycation plus people are looking at
national parks state parks nearby if you
look at the whole sharing data which i
think is really interesting
most of the booking levels are up to
about the same as they were before the
pandemic but with a couple of
interesting asterisks one people are
searching the word cabin more than they
ever have before March you understand
that's the kind of variation give me
give me two and then I've got a question
about cabins but tell me the second
point for okay well the second one is
people are booking at the last minute
because I think it's a dynamic situation
and it's it's there's a huge increase in
last-minute bookings about double what
it used to be so with cabins I've also
been cabin curious and I wonder from
your research are people interested in
the connection with nature that a cabin
might bring or the disconnection from
everyone else in their life that a cabin
might bring we are seeing that hotels
that offer sort of self-contained
accommodation sort of cabin style
accommodation wherever they are are
doing very well
so I think there is that sense but but I
think it's made us all reassess our
values and nature is a great thing to
kind of reboot ourselves yeah what do
you say to people who are on the fence
about travel they're not sure if the
recommendation is to stay home do they
feel guilty for going out that something
a lot of us are dealing with what would
you say to that kind of family right now
absolutely so obviously we wanted we
want to behave safely you want to follow
guidelines but remember when you're
sitting by the pool having a pinochle
you have no care in the world so it
feels like a total kind of you would
feel guilty doing something like this
like that when the circumstances right
now is so difficult but everyone around
you the cocktail waitress the room the
room attendant they're paying their
bills from your vacation travel is the
seventh largest private sector employer
in America supports about 16 million
jobs so if we want the economy to
rebound taking a vacation is a way to do
that markets are Vlad here so I've got a
question I was telling Tony that I'm not
that comfortable traveling I'm a huge
germaphobe and this period of Kovan my
fiance Marion likes to say that I can
now be morally self-righteous about
traveling what should we be looking for
in hotels in cabins Tony's cabin curious
what should we be looking for when we
visit these place as far as disinfecting
so I think what you'll see I would go
back to after 9/11 there was a there was
something called the theater of security
which was when we all wanted to be
reassured that real security measures
were being taken and they were sort of
broadcast to us 9/11 was a very good
peril a really tough time for the travel
industry we think there'll be a thing
like the theater of wellness so what
you'll see is all of those cleaning
protocols which are terrific and if you
check a hotel's website you can usually
see very detailed explanations of the
way they've upgraded them I think
they're gonna move cleaning the lobby
from 3:00 a.m. to 3:00 p.m. so when you
check in you'll sort of subtly reassured
that everything really is being cleaned
and if you if you're nervous honestly
Vlad you're not wrong I you know German
folks right now you're not alone just
get in touch with your hotel and say I'm
concerned can you tell me exactly what
you're doing and they will understand
that request you know you won't be the
only person asking all right that's a
good point there mark I also love your
point that if you can travel right now
if you can do it safely do it because
these hotels these restaurants as far as
they are depending on that business very
important point Mark Elwood thank you
very much